There are a lot of misconceptions when it comes to being low income,
and that's kind of why I wanted to start talking about it more,
because it is a taboo topic.
The only reason we were able to afford a home
is because my husband worked his butt off while I was in college
to save up for a down payment.
And by the sheer Grace of god,
we found a house that was an estate sale
and that was dirt cheap and needed a lot of fixing up.
You even bought it without me seeing it
because the housing market was that insane at the time.
My county's low income limit is 66 grand a year.
We make way less than that.
We live paycheck to paycheck,
and we don't get to do all the fun things that we would love to do.
But that doesn't mean that we can't own a home
or we can't have nice things.
And maybe we won't always be low income,
but I have no reason to lie about my financial status,
especially because there's shame and stigma around it.
Cheers to us who are low income but make it work!